Why are I beams shaped like an I?
Have you ever actually taken a moment to think
about this?
This simple technology forms the basis of
all our largest structures and even features
in one of the world’s most famous photos,
but after asking some of my friends few actually
knew the answer to this simple question.
The I beam is designed in that way to handle
a maximum bending load while using the least
amount of material.
Let’s look at an I beam supported on either
end to understand more.
When we apply a uniform load across this beam
the max deflection will occur here in the
middle.
We can calculate the deflection with this
equation.
This may look complicated, but it really isn’t.
W represents the uniformly distributed load
in terms of Newtons per metre, l is the span
between supports, E is the youngs modulus
which as explained in my Material Properties
101 video describes the stiffness of the material.
But the variable we want to focus on is this.
I represents the second moment of area sometimes
called the moment area of inertia.
This describes the shape of the beam, more
specifically it describes how the material
is distributed throughout the shape.
These two shapes have the same area, but that
area is distributed very differently and that
is important.
A see-saw is a good analogy for this idea.
When we place weight in the middle, it is
very easy to lift, in fact if it is placed
exactly over the middle, we aren’t lifting
it at all.
but the further we move that weight to the
end, the more difficult it is to lift, due
to the increasing leverage.
A very similar thing happens with beams in
bending.
Material at the centre of the beam, which
is called the neutral axis, does not resist
bending and the material furthest away from
the centre,resists the bending the most.
It is called the neutral axis because if we
place a bending load downward the same way
we did before, the beam will bend in a way
that will cause the lower edge to be in max
tension and the upper edge to be in max compression
and the values of stress gradually decrease
to 0 at the neutral axis where there is neither
tension or compression.
Because the tension and compression is maximum
the furthest from neutral axis we want to
maximise the amount of material on the outside
of the profile where it is needed most
The more material further from the neutral
axis the larger the second moment of area
will be.
Applying that to the equation we can see that
a larger second moment of area will result
in a smaller deflection.
So if we to place this section under the same
bending load, it would actually be stronger
if we flipped it over 90 degrees, because
more material now located future from the
neutral axis.
We could make it even stronger again, by reducing
this thickness to a minimum just enough to
resist the shear stress and placing that material
at the the top and suddenly we are back to
the I beam shape.
You can see this idea put into action all
around you.
In my last video I mentioned just one of them
when I spoke about the Willis Tower using
a bundled tube structure.
This structure maximises the amount of steel
on the outside of the building to maximise
it’s resistance to lateral bending from
wind and other loads.
I will be talking about another application
of this technology in my next video and if
you can think of any other examples of the
second moment of area being applied in the
world around you be sure to share it in the
comments.
Thanks for watching.
Like my last video I wanted to experiment
with a shorter format and it’s thanks to
sponsors like the TheGreatCoursesPlus that
allow me the freedom to do that.
They have been a fantastic supporter of this
channel over the last few months.
If you would like to learn more about subjects
like this they have a really great course
called every day engineering and they have
a huge range or other topics too.
Their courses give you indepth knowledge and
are taught by world renowned educators.
They added a new course by Niel De Grasse
Tyson recently or you can learn about photography,
history or even cooking.
If you would like to learn more head over
to TheGreatCoursesPLus.com/RealEngineering
for your free one month trial.
If you would like to see more content from
me the links to my patreon, Instagram, facebook
and twitter accounts are below